after reports of a party that was byob
today boris johnson was m.i.a the prime
minister has asked for an investigation
and his government came under fire in
parliament the prime minister retains
the confidence of the people of this
country confidence was not what came
across in the house of commons i think
mr speaker his absence speaks volumes as
does he smirks on the media the public
have already drawn their own conclusions
several mps expressed anger but also
pain
jim shannon was overcome with grief
after explaining his mother-in-law died
alone with coveted
a government investigation is already
underway into claims government staffers
on multiple occasions in 2020 broke
coveted 19 rules the latest gathering in
may revealed by british broadcaster itv
news which obtained a copy of the email
invite sent by johnson's private
secretary this pandemic for me is a
story of two men so one is my 55 year
old dad who is dead having spent 42
nights on a ventilator fighting covert
and no other illnesses the other is a
man who was 55 at the time of this party
boris johnson having survived covert
himself thought it was appropriate to
host a party where you could bring your
own boos the prime minister hasn't said
if he attended that party but mps on the
opposite side of the house will push him
on that wednesday as the prime minister
is expected to take questions in
parliament
crystal gamansen global news
london